[music]
So, I'm Sandar Fabber from Minurva
Humanoids. Uh, we're building humanoid
robots for the most dangerous jobs of
the planet, including oil and gas,
energy sector work, public safety work,
disposing of bombs, chemical units,
hazardous material disposal. Um and
we're on a mission to do that with
deployments actually before the end of
this year and some scaled real product
available sometime towards the end of
next year. So um before I start with the
opening frame, I'd like everybody to
give a quick oneliner of of each other
and then I'll introduce the panel.
>> Yes, thanks for the introduction. I'm
happy to start. My name is Florian
Visat. I'm from Synapticon. So we are
Germany stood based uh company uh
providing components to humanoids from
uh drives actuators and also full system
safety solution. My background is in
yeah software engineering for mobile
robots since 15 years and of course that
can drag along uh to humanoids. Now
>> hi everyone I'm Tolchinsky. I represent
Synopsis. Uh we provide software
solutions for simulation covering
everything from silicon to systems
complete systems. Uh my background is in
aerospace engineering. I used to do
design. I've done software particularly
safety critical software. So I have that
perspective and now I'm the product
manager for AI for synopsis.
>> Hi everyone. Uh I'm Arnab from Sapphira
AI. We are a Silicon Valley based uh
company working on automating functional
safety and security workflows. So we
spend most of our time really trying to
bridge those two worlds and make sure
that embodied AI is an inherently safe
and secure product. Um my background is
I've spent most of my career as a
systems engineer in automotive and
robotics. Um and yeah that's basically
what uh we're now moving into the
humanoid uh world as well.
>> Hi everyone. Uh my name is Jason CTO of
Vig One. U V1 is a subsidiary of T micro
and specialize in physical AI security
such as automotive security or robotic
security and prior to V1 uh I was the
chief architect of T micro. Thank you.
>> Amazing. Thank you all. So I would like
to introduce the panel which is about
securing the machine um and also about
safety. So, first I would like to
outline those two concepts and maybe
have you guys also pitch in a little bit
and helping me build an understanding of
what safety and security means and how
they are different. Firstly, um our
perspective or my perspective has been
that security is the attack path, but
safety is actually hurting people next
to you potentially and making sure that
you're not actually falling on them. So
security really concerns itself with,
you know, potentially the building
burning itself down by some malicious
attack vector surfacing itself within
your humanoid robot and doing things
that are not great to your building.
Whereas um safety is more about how do
we make sure that during normal
operation and potentially when uh
compromised how do we make sure that
humans around the robot do not get hurt
and just generally more about the public
safety as well given the fact that we're
doing a lot of work in that space. Um
yeah so would you guys agree with that
concept? Is there anything you guys want
to add to this?
>> Yeah I think the the functional safety
part that cares about the the human. So
the only thing we care about is that uh
no human gets injured and the the
security part that's also for protecting
data protecting values but in in the end
uh function safety uh is just about
preventing humans from being injured.
So we don't care if the borrow breaks
and if the building uh breaks down it's
just about humans inside that
environment.
um as systems get more and more complex
and we start adding more layers of
autonomy and AI into these systems the
security risks also start growing
exponentially. So it is very important
to understand and manage your systems
security and safety risk. Right? So what
security
uh compromise leads to what safety
event. If it is a safety event that
doesn't affect your safety case, you
probably don't have to pay attention to
it. But you need to know that
consciously, right? This is about making
sure you understand your security and
safety posture. Make sure that you have
a clearly defined security and safety
posture with the product you're putting
out there and understanding how you're
going to actually make sure your product
complies with that. It's not just about
building guard rails for your AI, but
it's also about making sure that when
those guardrails fail, there is an
actual safety mechanism that stops the
robot from, as Florian said, hurting
human beings or violating your safety
case that you set up. So having this
whole system end to end in a dynamic
fashion that lets you make decisions at
rapid speed um is important because
hackers don't stop, right? People are
going to keep trying to hack systems.
There are there are different ways to
spoof systems these days. The more
intelligence you add, the more
opportunity you open up for different
security vulnerabilities. So keeping on
top of those and making sure you
understand their impact is is absolutely
key.
>> I second on that. Uh I think security
and safety cannot be two separate work
working workstream. Yeah. So safety is
about deterministic failure and security
is about undeterministic failure
manipulated by attackers. Yeah. So I
would say um security especially cyber
security is is one of the fundamental
pillar of safety.
May maybe just to add that when I think
about the interaction between the two
security is dealing with a malicious
threat right safety is often considered
just like you say accidents happening
making sure your system is going to be
behave and uh not cause any injuries but
you really have to consider malicious
threat and its impact on safety.
>> Absolutely. Thank you guys. So three
years ago um to just take a look at what
this space looks like at the moment.
Three years ago it really was data was
really the final the final layer of all
um kind of safety and security problems.
Robotics weren't really going to come
out of the labs and now they are right.
So now that that data poisoning or red
teaming attack um that is a lot more
serious that can actually become a whole
issue. um it can literally take down not
just a single company but potentially
investor um kind of belief and
confidence in the entire sector. So we
all sort of have this um responsibility
and this mutual care for for not doing
that but at the same time we also don't
have defined standards that we need to
abide by and there is clear market
competition that's global right so
that's that's the pressure under which
most robotics companies operate today
and I think one of the really important
aspects of this is really how can our
robots be abused or or potentially uh
put to something that's that's malicious
so I would like to ask to the panel
um what an attacker can do to an
intelligent potentially humanoid or
other form of a human of a robot that is
um that can be potentially malicious.
How can we mitigate these threats and
what has really changed over the course
of the last three years? What has been
the biggest trend that you guys have
seen that's really exposing that
vulnerable that that threatening surface
that we need to protect ourselves
against from a from a security
standpoint?
>> Yeah. Uh I think vehicles are probably
the first uh connected intelligence
machines deploy at scale in the real
world. Yeah. And vehicle already tell us
what can go wrong. I I just give an
example. In March this year around 100
Apollo go robot taxi froze
simultaneously on the elevator highway
or the major intersection in Wuhan,
China. Um the due cost uh was not
disclosed but we know there must be a
mechanism that can freeze the entire
fleet at once right. Yeah. And talking
about robotics uh we all know that last
year there was a warmable uh Bluetooth
vulnerability discovered in the unitary
robots. Uh actually they have a booth
out there but I believe they already
patch it and you just need to compromise
one robot and that robot become a moving
attacking station. Right? Imagine that
robot return to the shares charging
station and that robot can use exact the
same Bluetooth vulnerability to
compromise the rest of the fleet right
yeah so a physical proximity is no
longer an excuse to ignore that's that
kind of threat and I think in recent
year the trending is about AI nobody
will argue about that and we all know
that AI models are not perfect it can be
fooled by prompt injection or several
image patches and and we'll soon be
seeing that people start to deploy AI
agent onto onto the robot to handle more
complex uh tasks and you know that will
introduce new risks like indirect prompt
injection malicious skills or MCPS right
and actually there worth over 300
malicious scale discovered in this
February on the cloud hub the open cloud
uh registry this February yeah so you
don't even need to compromise the robot
you just interact with them right yeah
you can then you can mislead them so I I
What I want to say is um those attack
services and threat and attack
mechanisms are there. They are real, but
this time it's about safety and you
don't want to wait until it happens,
right? Yeah.
>> And may maybe to add to that, you said
that the uh the humanoids are much more
complex and much more capable today
compared to three years ago. So that's
also what we see as a difference
compared to industrial robots, cobalts
or AMRs because if you have an
industrial robot that's typically uh
screwed to the floor or to the ceiling.
So if that um gets hacked and gets uh
unexpected movements, you will know that
the uh uh area where you can have people
injured is limited. That's similar
[snorts] for AMRs. So they typically are
big, bulky, so they just have a limited
operating space. So they probably have
few chances to escape the actual factory
hall or climb upstairs or go down
somewhere. But if you think of humanoids
today, they might just climb the stair.
They might just open the door and then
they can basically be everywhere. So the
the risk is not uh only is
[clears throat] not anymore limited to a
certain area where you operate the
robots. Um they can basically operate
everywhere and that's what what I see as
a big difference for the functional
safety part. So uh yes
>> um and I think just to add to everything
my colleague said here uh we have to
keep in mind the way you actually
threaten or create threat pots to these
machines is also evolving right so you
have the very sophisticated attacks
where you could build agents to attack
uh but you can also actually just misuse
the intended function uh just as an
example uh you know couple like last
year people in San Francisco were buying
t-shirts that had a stop sign on them
and standing on the side of the road
when a Whimo passed by and the car would
break. Right? That is not a failure.
That is actually what if the car sees a
stop sign, it is supposed to stop. But
people were now spoofing this, right?
This is obviously security is a
non-deterministic thing, right? No one
who worked at Whimo thought that this
was going to be the issue they'd be
fighting, but that was the issue you
start fighting. So, your threat
landscape is going to evolve. Um, and
the number of threats you're going to
have to deal with also will evolve. Now,
as a company, as a robot manufacturer,
as a humanoid manufacturer, you have to
really make sure you're prioritizing
correctly, making sure that the uh the
safety issue caused by these security
events is something that you should be
mitigating. Uh or if there are ways
around where you think that is not a
part of your safety case, maybe those
are not the places you should spend your
time. So, uh it does also come back to
an optimization problem, especially as
you scale your product.
I think we're we're in a phase where
we're discovering the unknown unknowns,
right? And uh it will take us some time
to uh for these things to surface and
I'm confident we will address them as
they come.
>> Awesome. Thanks. So for a case study
that the audience might be familiar
with, we have seen a powerful model
being um kind of uh tricked into writing
um safety critical software for sort of
against a government a national security
uh system and it was able to achieve
really impressive results as a result of
which the government under under which
that company was operating they decided
to take down the model for three weeks
and then put it back on the open market.
My first question to you regarding this,
can we actually prepare for a future
attack by an AI model that has
capabilities that we are not aware of?
>> I think we have to be prepared for uh
for events like that. Um in general,
again, you know, the guardrails that we
build around the system is probably step
zero. We cannot send a system that
actually interacts with the physical
world without guardrails. But we need to
make sure we have mechanisms in place
that actually make sure the system is
safe when those guardrails fail. Now
understanding what the failure of that
guardrail can lead to and what the
proliferation of that can be in terms of
safety events. That is where uh this
becomes key. Um earlier you could have
very deterministic linear safety events.
Right? So if a brake fails those are the
things that happen in terms of safety.
If there's a misdetection for a vehicle
or a misdetection for a humanoid, the
the following things are are an issue.
But as we scale these these models and
essentially get them to start hacking
the systems, we need to make sure we're
tracing that full chain of safety events
as well. So to make sure that we
essentially don't violate our own safety
cases and for this, it again goes back
to making sure you have a very
comprehensive and important uh safety
case that you're actually working
towards.
Yeah. So my answer to that would be I
think the approach should be that we
clearly separate the AI system from the
safety system so that if the uh non-safe
AI eventually gets hacked or does
something unexpected that we still have
a second layer which can jump in which
is deterministic which is proven by stat
statistical measures uh and have
eventually a TV a certification for
something that uh that really was
undergone a validation
process and those system they have to be
prepared to jump in if something happens
on the layers above.
I
>> think we need to figure out the the
governance right things will happen and
we won't need to be able to jump in but
with time again we need to figure out
how we decide when we let's say pull the
plug and who's in charge and
what we need to react to.
>> Exactly. Okay, so my next question was
going to be actually should a government
be able to put a plug on an AI model if
if they don't work out and and how how
does that work? Right? So in our case, I
mean in Munar where we deploy humanoid
robots on critical assets like oil rigs.
If you put the plug on the humanoids,
then they just collapse and actually
create a massive like safety hazard. So
that obviously is not a solution to the
problem and there's not really an
obvious solution. What do you guys think
about this? who should be able to pull
the plug and how should that work?
>> I I personally I I prefer to assume the
attackers they will have access to those
powerful model. Yeah. At least with the
similar capability. Yeah. So the defense
really cannot depends on the the tool
availability or model availability to
the to the attackers, right? We get to
be prepared and unfortunately there
there is no single silver bullet. So
what we're doing is uh we're trying to
build a a system for our security loop
engineering. Yeah, attackers will scan
your source code or your binary using
those powerful model. So why not you
scan first, right? You you raise the
bar, right? You try to minimize the test
service for those unknown and uh you you
try to detect those unknown unknowns by
anomaly detection in the wrong time and
you try to generate the security
incidents uh with context what happened
before and after in your continuous
monitoring system and you keep improving
through the cycles right so so that's my
answer we cannot depends on the
availability the tool availability to
the attackers so you ask what should
happen if somebody pulls the plug so my
view on that from the functional safety
perspective is it doesn't matter who
pulls the plug. If there's a a power uh
failure, if there's a communication
failure, if the system got hacked, if
somebody uh uh shuts it down uh on
purpose, uh what we have to make sure is
that if this happens that if you have a
balanced humanoid, it does not fall over
uncontrolled. So our approach is to have
it uh fall at least nicely. So we cannot
prevent that this goes wrong but at
least we can make it fall away from
persons for example or crouch in a
compact position instead of full speed
crashing towards a person on the floor.
So that will this is all measures to
prevent the uh uh risk we u expose to
humans.
I think in in addition to that we also
need to have a governance and
regulations in terms of what a fail a
safe fail state is. So for a humanoid if
you know if it just collapses if you
have a home robot you definitely don't
want that to collapse on a child or
something or or anything along those
lines. You want to make sure that you
know as an industry as we deploy these
technologies get them to proliferate
more into industry into consumer uh
spaces uh as a regulatory body and as an
industry we really define how these
systems are supposed to fail uh when
those fail measures go go live and as
Florian said earlier making sure we have
an architecture in place that allows the
system to fail. So if something is
compromised, a backup system can take
over and ensure the correct failure and
the intended failure instead of a um of
an unintended failure.
>> I don't think I have much to add, but I
do strongly feel there should be a
second redundant separated system from
the AI that can pull the plug and also
come to a say safe landing.
So to summarize there there should be a
certifiable way of having some safety
procedure that we follow in case there's
a breakdown and if there's a breakdown
then there should be a lower layer
safety level that should be potentially
defined in the silicon or in the
hardware. What would that look like or
what does that look like at synopsis at
the moment?
>> Yeah, I mean we we really focused on
introducing the safety layer at the the
silicon level, right? And then you have
uh things being stacked on top. So then
you have firmware uh you have the
operating system you have the the AI AI
model itself and um if something goes
wrong you really need to set you need to
set up processes so that if something
goes wrong you can really trace where
the problem came came from so you can
work towards resol resolving it making
sure it doesn't happen in the future.
Yes, I I support it this uh safety
functional safety is a parame. So you
have to start from the hardware layer uh
from the the compute uh from the
firmware from the actuator uh safety
features and then you can stack on top
of that u maybe safe camera inputs and
then add software layers for uh
detecting uh persons for calculating
kinematics of a humanoid for letting it
fall uh in a nice way and then
everything on top of that uh sits the AI
uh which potentially also needs a
monitoring system on the safety Right.
But you you cannot start you cannot have
a safe humanoid if you don't start with
the lower level of of these uh safety
pyramid with safe actuators with safe
camera inputs.
No chance. So safety is not just a
sticker you can put on a a ready
deployed humanoid. You have to start
from the beginning. I think on top of
the hardware loot of trust is it's also
important to run software in the loop
simulation with your actual robot UD
URDF or USD in a simulation environment.
That's the only way you can tell uh can
your robot fail safe when a certain
software component is being compromised.
Yeah. And I think the more layers of the
stack that you add uh and if you don't
run your safety workflow through these
layers, you're just pushing it deeper in
uh which later adds to a compounding
problem. So um in the design process,
this needs to be uh something that is
taken into account uh as as the product
is built up.
>> Great. There seems to be some
disagreement actually in the panel about
whether safety and security should be
coupled or whether it should be
separated and whether there is benefits
or sort of potential threats arising
from them them being coupled or
separated. So I actually want to ask the
question can we honestly certify a
system um being secure without having a
steady certification on it or vice
versa. Can we actually do a
certification for one but not the other?
Should that be a possibility or should
we only have certifications for both at
the same time?
that that that's a good question. So you
cannot have either or uh I think it
needs both uh in the end. It's just a
question of how are they stacked on top
of each other. So in in our opinion the
functional safety part. So making sure
that if something fails that we fail
safe uh and don't create risk for
humanoids. That's that's the very lowest
layer and then security probably comes
on top of that to prevent that something
somebody gets access to the humanoid at
all. I I agree with Flurry and I think
it is a layered system, right? So if you
do have a certifiable safe a functional
safety system, so that tells you how the
system is supposed to fail exactly what
your safety goals are. You can then add
the security layer to make sure that in
the event of those being triggered, you
have a failsafe mechanism. In an ideal
world, you never see your functional
safety mechanisms and work because you
know things are secure, your security
system is as good as it can be and no
one's ever hacked it. But the truth is
that in some cases they they will be
hacked. Uh and when they are we want to
make sure that there is a security
system that a safety system that comes
in to to save the day. So it is a
layered stack and I do believe that the
entire system needs to be certified with
a safety and a security flow.
I I think
>> um yeah I agree you need to have both in
in my mind security can be done it can
be isolated from safety in terms of
establishing
if system is secure or not but then the
safety part analysis has to uh say
assume that security has been breached
right and then make make sure that you
handle it in the best way I mean in in
my mind I I'm thinking of you know the
aerospace fields or even even driving
right we have humans in the loop which
we cannot fully predict the behavior of
I mean somebody may just fall asleep at
the wheel or you know have a heart
attack at the wheel the safety system
needs to handle such a situation so for
me it's a similar thing where we cannot
guarantee what the AI will do but we
need to create a safe system nonetheless
>> awesome so just in test of time uh my
final question is what do you guys see
as the biggest gap that industry is
currently ignoring ing where you think
that that gap should be bridged ASAP.
>> Uh from my perspective it's about cyber
security. Yeah, I know most of the robot
makers they are still focused on
functional safety. That's the reality.
Yeah. But again, I think uh cyber
security is the foundation of functional
safety, right? So without cyber cyber
security, it's really hard to guarantee
uh your function safety can work under
undeterministic cases. Yeah.
Yeah, I think bridging the security and
safety gap is what the industry isn't
working on right now. The typical
process is build what you have first uh
do a safety certification because that's
what you need to deploy and then last
step you'd run a security workflow. Um
as these models get more complex and the
products get more complex, I think that
is something that would set you up for
failure. So having this be an integrated
process where you're able to actually
make sure that your safety and security
are linked, you understand your
end-to-end uh safety and security
posture is going to be very important to
deliver a successful product.
Yeah. So maybe I'm oversimplifying now,
but what does it take to build a
humanoid? You need the physical AI. So
the the AI part that's data and AI
models. I think that's covered today in
industry. So at least everybody's
talking about that. uh also building
physical robots. Uh that's what
everybody is doing. So that's solved.
But what is not addressed today is the
functional safety part. And that's the
third dimension which I think you need
to address to get the humanoids out of a
a cage and operate in a factory
environments in semi-public environments
and eventually also in private homes
someday.
>> I'll just second that. [snorts]
>> Awesome. Thank you all very much for
your input. Really appreciate this chat.
Thank you all.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. Thank you.